You've probably heard
this a million times.
The conflicts tearing the Middle East
apart are fueled by ancient hatreds.
Religious feuds that
have simmered for centuries.
But what if that's not
the real story at all?
What if the bloodshed that we are seeing
in the headlines stems from
things that are more recent?
Like 20th century
borders drawn by foreigners,
modern propaganda,
and power plays.
Today we're going to dismantle the 10
biggest myths that are used to explain
and justify these narratives.
And spot the real forces
shaping the world today.
Myth 1. It's an age-old
region of endless hatred.
This is perhaps the most
persistent myth of all.
That the conflicts in the Middle East are
the inevitable result of hatreds that
stretch back to time immemorial.
But the truth is far more recent.
The modern borders of countries like
Syria and Iraq were largely drawn by
European diplomats in 1916 with the
Sykes-Picot Agreement.
This, along with later British and French
mandates, carved up the region without
any regard for the
people who were living there.
Forcing rival ethnic and religious groups
into brand new states.
The chaos we see today is not
the outcome of ancient feuds.
It's the direct painful fallout of
colonial lines drawn on
a map over a century ago.
Myth 2. Foreign powers
are there to bring peace.
History tells a very different story.
From the proxy wars of the Cold War,
where superpowers were
arming opposite sides,
to the 2003 invasion of Iraq,
foreign intervention has almost always
acted as an accelerant.
Instead of bringing stability,
these actions have almost consistently
been pouring gasoline on local fires.
They've armed factions, destabilized
governments, and in some instances
created power vacuums that allowed
extremist groups like
ISIS to rise from the ashes.
Myth 3. The Iraq-Iran war was just a
Sunni-Shia-Holy war.
While sectarian differences were used as
a powerful propaganda tool,
the war's origins were rooted in
geopolitics, not theology.
Saddam Hussein, a Sunni, feared that
Iran's 1979 Islamic revolution
would inspire Iraq's own Shia majority to
rise up against him. His
invasion was in the crusade.
It was a calculated land grab aimed to
secure the vital Shat-al-Arab waterway
and to crush a political movement before
it could gain traction.
It was a war for power and territory
cloaked in the language of religion.
Myth 4. The Lebanese Civil War was just a
Muslim versus Christian conflict.
The conflict was ignited by a
power-sharing system
established by a French-era constitution
known as the National Pact,
that no longer reflected
the country's demographics.
This political inequality was made bigger
by social disparities.
When the Palestinian Liberation
Organization, or PLO, arrived and created
a state within a state,
it added another explosive layer.
Alliances constantly shifted and
frequently crossed religious lines,
while neighboring Israel and
Syria poured fuel on the fire,
turning Lebanon into a proxy battlefield
for their own agendas.
Myth 5. Jews have no
historic connection to the land.
A popular claim is that modern-day Israel
is a purely colonial enterprise with no
authentic roots in the region. But both
archaeology and
historical records confirm
a continuous Jewish presence in the land
dating back 3000 years.
Long before the modern Zionist movement
began, Jewish communities existed there.
The wave of immigration in the 19th and
20th century was seen by
those arriving as a return
to their historic homeland, where their
people were already living, not an
invasion into a foreign land.
Myth 6. Israel struck without any
provocation in the 1976 war. The
narrative that Israel launched
a surprise unprovoked attack in 1967
omits critical events that
led up to that first shot.
In the weeks before the war, Egypt
expelled UN peacekeepers that were there
to keep the tensions
down. Then it moved a massive amount of
troops into the Sinai
desert right on Israel's border.
Finally, Egypt blockaded the Straits of
Tiran, cutting off
Israel's primary shipping route.
An act widely considered a declaration of
war under maritime law.
Facing armies gathering on
three sides and facing direct threats of
annihilation, Israel decided
to launch a preemptive strike.
Myth 7. The term "Palestinian" has always
referred exclusively to Arabs.
Words matter and the word "Palestinian"
has a history that's often overlooked.
Until the middle of the 20th century, the
term was geographic, not
ethnic. It described everybody
living in the region then known as
Palestine, regardless of
their ethnicity or faith.
There were Palestinian Jews, Palestinian
Christians and Palestinian Muslims.
Local newspapers, orchestras and even
passports issued by the
British Mandate used the term
"Palestinian" to describe all three
groups. The idea of
"Palestinian" as an exclusively
Arab concept solidified later, in
parallel with the rise of
modern Arab nationalism.
Myth 8. The displacement of the
Palestinians is a uniquely unresolved
tragedy. In the 1948 war,
around 700,000 Palestinians fled or were
expelled from their homes,
creating an international
refugee crisis that plays an important
role in the conflict today.
What is often left out in this
story is that in the same time period,
the same number of Jews were
forced out of Arab countries
around the Middle East and North Africa.
The vast number of these
Jewish refugees were resettled,
primarily in Israel. The political
decision to perpetuate one group's
refugee status while
ignoring the others has become a major
obstacle to find a genuine
solution to the conflict today.
Myth 9. Israel was a massive underdog
against Arab armies in
1948. On paper, the odds looked
impossible for the newly created state of
Israel. The surrounding Arab
armies had a clear advantage
when it came to manpower and conventional
military hardware. However,
wars aren't fought on paper.
The Arab forces were poorly coordinated,
often operating with
conflicting national objectives
rather than a unified strategy. In
contrast, the Israeli military, while
lacking heavy weaponry,
were highly organized and fighting with
the desperate
motivation of sheer survival.
This organization and fighting spirit
proved decisive factors
leading to their victory.
Myth 10. The Arab world is inherently
violent or culturally
backward. This is a classic
Orientalist trope that's both racist and
historically ignorant.
It conveniently ignores
the Islamic Golden Age, a period when the
region was the global
center for science, medicine and
culture while Europe was in the Dark
Ages. It also conveniently ignores
Europe's own history
with violence, including the two world
wars in the 20th century. The turmoil
seen in the Middle East
today has clear modern causes, the toxic
legacy of colonialism, the distorting
politics of oil wealth
and the generations of dictators propped
up by foreign powers.
Not some imaginary cultural
defect. If you are finding this breakdown
valuable and feel like
you're learning something new,
please comment down below. The conflicts
in the Middle East are not
destiny, they are not the
inevitable result of hatred baked into
the culture. They are the
direct product of modern history,
of lines on a map, of calculated
propaganda and of cynical
power politics. When we finally
ditch the ancient hatred storyline we can
start to see the
situation for what it really is.
We can see the real choices, the real
interests and most importantly the real
people behind every single headline.